[Music]
so what do the players get if they
accept the deal that is on the table the
deal that the nfl
formally accepted yesterday when the
owners got together well one of the
things is how they cut the pie 48.5
percent is what the total output will be
for the players and there's always going
to be exceptions deductions and things
get a little screwy before you start
carving it up but it's a good percentage
the better percentage than what they
currently get and
that gives them a motivation to grow the
pie as much as possible that's one of
the reasons why i think d smith is
pushing this now because if you get
better tv deals that's more money that
ultimately goes to the players via the
money that's available under the salary
cap some other highlights big cat
minimum salary would go up 90 000
right away for all players and look we
we talk about guys making 25 30 million
a year all the time there are a lot of
guys who are making the absolute minimum
you kick it up by 90 000
that's a significant bump also four more
players per roster when they go to 17
games more jobs more players that's
something that players have wanted a big
concession that we never thought the
league would make now they haven't
gotten rid of the marijuana policy if
they accept this new proposal but the
marijuana policy is basically going to
be gutted they will reduce the testing
window from
late april to early august so you have
to stay clean the whole time until your
number comes up for your annual
marijuana test it's going to be reduced
to a two-week window so you only have to
be clean for that two weeks and you no
longer have to be as clean as you used
to be several years ago they moved the
minimum threshold of thc metabolites or
whatever the specific term is to 35
nanograms now they're gonna move it to
150 and noted marijuana expert chris
sims tells me it takes about five days
to get under 150 nanograms and he knows
that from experience so he he likes that
now again it doesn't cost the owners
anything big cat we saw this a lot in
2011. when it's time to get the deal
done all of a sudden the owners start
making concessions on all sorts of
things that cost them nothing and
actually the current marijuana policy
does cost the owners because it keeps
quality players off the field for no
good reason that will end for the most
part under this new cba that's a
no-brainer and i you know if you've ever
been around football players and pro
athletes like a lot of guys
use it recreationally for pain
management in states that are legal like
this is the evolving times here where
you have to you have to kind of catch up
with you know people's thoughts around
marijuana and looking across the country
and how many states have it legalized
and how ridiculous it is that the nfl
would basically have strict policies
it's crazy so it's smart that they're
doing this because i think this is
actually a big point for the players
that they basically are making these
tests uh stupidity tests like can you
stop smoking weed for five days and if
you can do that then you can play and
you're fine so it's smart that they're
doing that and i agree with you like
this is
it's funny how nfl owners always have a
few things that they can basically give
to the players that really don't end up
costing them anything and it looks like
they're negotiating and they're always
negotiating from a place of strength
because at the end of the day we've seen
it with the lockouts or the you know
threatened lockouts guys don't want to
go
from you know a season of playing
football and getting paid millions to
not getting paid millions and sitting on
their couch i wouldn't either i don't
blame the players one bit it's just a
very hard position to be in if you
potentially are losing millions and
millions of dollars in the prime of your
career over a cba that should get signed
and i don't want to go too far down the
rabbit hole now i spoke at length about
this last hour big cat but i wonder
whether or not the union model even
works for the players and let me explain
this as simply as i can because you're
not going to have players who want to
miss football games and want to give up
gigantic salaries for a full year to
exert maximum leverage on the owners i
think the better approach for the
players could be let the cba expire
decertify the union and then let the
league implement its rules and you just
sue them into as you would say bolivian
over every rule that these 32
independent businesses are trying to
apply to its collective workforce
because let me tell you big cat the
antitrust violations are rampant if you
take away the protection that comes from
having a unionized workforce you take
away a unionized workforce the franchise
tag antitrust violation salary cap
antitrust violation the draft antitrust
violation that may be the best way for
the players to attack the league now
and that's exactly what happened with
the reggie white and i trust lawsuit
after the failed strike the union had an
anti-trust lawsuit that lasted for five
years they had the nfl on the ropes and
they got free agency that way they may
need to think about going back to that
to get their best possible deal okay i
don't understand anything you just said
it makes no sense to me but i will take
your word for it you were a lawyer
everyone knows mike florio never lost to
casey one so i'm
makes sense but but let me make sure let
me make sure you understand when because
the nfl isn't one unified business it's
32 different businesses and
when they start having rules among 32
businesses like mcdonald's burger king
taco bell all having rules about how
much we're going to pay and how much
money is available to pay our workers
and how we can trade workers from one to
the other and we draft our workers
coming in it would be treated as 32
unique businesses and it would be chaos
there would be no draft there would be
no franchise tag you would sign a
contract with your employer and when it
ends you go wherever you want to go that
may be the best way for the players to
attack every antitrust violation without
a union to give the league cover and to
give the league an exemption from
anti-trust violations that may be the
way to do it that may be the only way to
get the best possible deal if they're
not prepared to do that if they're not
prepared to go on strike they just need
to take this deal you're the candidate
of change i mean that's i i don't care
again i don't understand it candidate of
chaos i i love it i i think it makes
sense i'm sure someone smarter than both
of us will say that's stupid but i like
it it's a low bar
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports